DAN: WELCOME BACK TO
"UNFILTERED."
FIRST THE SUPREME COURT UPHELD
YOUR SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS,
THEN THEY OVERTURNED ROE VERSUS
WADE.
NOW THE LEFT IS MELTING DOWN
WITH THE POSSIBILITY THE HIGH
COURT COULD PUT A STOP TO THE
PRACTICE OF USING RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION IN THE COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS PROCESS.
PROCESS.
THIS IS BY NATURE RACIST.
YOU CAN'T GIVE PREFERENCE TO ONE
GROUP BASED ON RACE WITHOUT
TAKING IT FROM SOMEONE ELSE.
IT SHOULDN'T EXIST IN A COLOR
BLIND COUNTRY.
>> WE HAVE KNOWN FOR MANY
DECADES THAT THE AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION AS PRACTICED IN THIS
COUNTRY VIOLATES THE 1964 CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT AS WELL AS THE EQUAL
PROTECTION CLAUSE OF THE 14th
AMENDMENT.
AND WE HAVE BEEN WILLING AS A
NATION TO TOLERATE THE
DISCRIMINATORY BEHAVIOR BECAUSE
IT WAS THOUGHT THAT IT WAS
TEMPORARY AND EVENTUALLY IT
WOULD BE ELIMINATED.
BUT WHAT WE FIND WITH THE CRT
AND THE MOVE AWAY FROM
NON-DISCRIMINATION TO OPENLY
DISCRIMINATION.
THE OPEN DISCRIMINATION WE SEE
AGAINST WHITES AND ASIANS TAKING
PLACE, IT'S TIME FOR THE COURT
TO STEP IN AND RESTORE THE LAW
AND THE CONSTITUTION.
DAN: I WOULD LIKE TO GET YOUR
QUICK THOUGHTS ON THIS VIDEO,
THE LEFT FREAKING AND MAKING
NAZI COMPARISONS IF
CONSERVATIVES DO WELL TUESDAY.
>> THIS COUNTRY IS ON TRACK TO
REPEAT WHAT HAPPENED IN GERMANY
WHEN IT WAS THE GREATEST
DEMOCRACY GOING ELECTED A
CHANCELLOR WHO CO-OPTED THE
MEDIA.
>> AN HISTORIAN WOULD SAY WHAT
WAS AT STAKE THIS WEEK WOULD BE
WHETHER OUR CHILDREN WILL BE
ARRESTED AND CONCEIVABLY KILLED.
WE ARE ON THE EDGE OF A BRUTAL
AUTHORITARIAN SYSTEM.
DAN: I'M GETTING TIRED OF THE
NAZI COMPARISONS, WE ARE ALL
GOING TO DIE, THREATS TO
DEMOCRACY.
THIS IS BEYOND OLD AT THIS
POINT.
>> HOPEFULLY THEY DON'T REALLY
BELIEVE WHAT THEY ARE SAYING.
I THINK THE AVERAGE AMERICAN
WOULD REJECT THAT TYPE OF
COMPARISON.
THE RHETORIC IS SO EVIL AND MEAN
SPIRITED, I THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WOULD BE ABLE TO SEE
THROUGH IT.
IT WOULD BE UNFORTUNATE IF THOSE
PEOPLE ACTUALLY BELIEVED WHAT
THEY ARE SAYING.
IF THEY BELIEVED WHAT THEY WERE
SAYING, THEY WOULD NOT BE
HOLDING POLITICAL PRISONERS FROM
JANUARY 6.
THEY WOULD NOT BE PUSHING AND
EMBRACING ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
THEY WOULD BE FOLLOWING